la cuestión política va muy vinculada en
cuanto a las políticas públicas y una de
las políticas públicas que más me
inquieta es la referente a la violencia
familiar a la violencia que sufrimos las
mujeres sufrimos la violencia en
cuestión política sufrimos la violencia
en las calles sufrimos la violencia
en el aspecto laboral sufrimos la
violencia en el aula
me ha tocado muchas veces la jurídica y
escuchar muchas historias de mujeres que
sufren violencia
y en ese sentido yo les he preguntado a
las mujeres qué es lo que quieren que
haga cómo quieren que les ayude
les cuestionó a las mujeres y les
pregunto cuál es el tipo de violencia
que han sufrido
les explico que está la violencia
psicológica que está la física que está
la económica
y les pregunto
qué es lo que quieren que haga porque
generalmente nosotros tenemos que dar el
preámbulo
el hecho es que jamás pensé que esa
pregunta me la tenía que hacer a mí
misma
sufrí violencia y entonces cómo le haces
tú que das asesoría
cómo le haces tú para responderte esa
pregunta y decir qué es lo que quieren
que hagan por ti
alrededor mío
las personas mis amigos mis familiares
todos me dicen hace esto hasta aquello y
les digo a ver necesito tiempo necesito
ayuda para poder tomar una decisión
entonces
tengo el conocimiento de ley este es un
conocimiento de instituciones
sé cuáles son los pasos
pero sé que antes de acudir a cualquier
instancia lo que se tiene que hacer es
responder esa pregunta qué es lo que
quieres
y entonces
lo que hago es acudir a apoyo porque
antes del jurídico está lo espiritual lo
personal yo me sentía quebrada
sentía que ya no que mi proyecto ya no
estaba
vivo que lo habían matado
y la persona que me da la asesoría me
dice
porque has llegado hasta este punto
yo también me vuestra pregunta cómo he
llegado hasta este punto cuando cuando
se todas las cuestiones que van pasando
cuando sé que la violencia es una bola
pequeñita que va creciendo
no se detiene
va creciendo
tendrás la ilusión de que se detiene
pero no es así
lo que pasa es como les han contado
muchas veces lo de la olla caliente
donde están los sapos que se le va
aumentando el calor y los sapos se van
acostumbrando hasta que fallece así es
la violencia te vas acostumbrando a
vivirla
se te va haciendo común
lavazza siendo parte de tu vida
hasta que no ocurre algo que te hace
despertar
todos los demás observaban porque la
única persona capaz de decidir decir ya
no más es uno mismo
y entonces acudo con la persona que me
va a ayudar en este duelo y en este
procedimiento en este seguimiento para
poder tomar una decisión nadie puede
tomar la más que tú
y me dice como primera tarea
haz una lista de las cosas buenas y de
las cosas malas ok
y también quiero que te hagas una
pregunta
cómo sería tu vida con él y sin él ok
en el momento en que empiezo a hacer las
respuestas es un momento verdaderamente
doloroso porque sí que ciertamente había
cosas buenas
pero había más malas
una vez que regresó con la tarea me dice
cómo te fue
ya tengo una decisión y que has pensado
tengo antes de decir lo bueno y lo malo
quiero comentar
como me proyecto con el ok es mucho
mi primer escenario
lo primero que veo si sigo con esta
persona cuáles me veo enferma
ok y cuál es tu segundo escenario me veo
en prisión
y cuál es tu tercer escenario
me veo muerto
la persona me escucha
y le digo
ya sé lo que quiero
yo no puedo continuar más
humanamente he hecho todo lo que he
podido hacer
no es mi lucha
y entonces
ya tienes tu decisión ya no la vas a
cambiar
no por mí
ni por mis hijos
y más porque muchas personas implicadas
hay muchos que están detenidos diciendo
nos esperamos a saber cuál es tu
decisión
en el momento que la comparto
todos dicen que
entonces habló con él y le digo he
tomado esta decisión
nos vamos a divorciar
y como se todos los procedimientos
y sé que se podría conflictuar porque
podría hacerlo pero sé que él
conflictuar lo nuevamente tendría que
salir a flote todo lo vivido y yo ya
quería dejarlo atrás
y le digo más de archivos involuntario
estos son los términos del convenio ya
no vas a hablar conmigo vas a hablar con
otra persona
el acepta
no podía decir que no
no podía negarse le convenía
dentro del mismo convenio
yo voy a citar
que se necesita ayuda la ayuda la están
tomando mis hijos y la estoy tomando yo
pero también la necesita
entonces dentro del convenio señaló que
él también tiene que ir ayuda
para poder convivir con los menores
porque de qué caso tiene que los menores
están trabajando en su autoestima en su
relación en construirse a sí mismos
cuando viene
y es un factor tóxico y ellos están
tratando de estar sanos y entonces
acepta
y me dice quiero hablar contigo
y entonces le comento la persona que me
está haciendo el seguimiento es que
quiere hablar conmigo no tú no hablas
con él
a solas si es que quisieras hablar con
él ve acompañado ok no
le digo yo no quiero volver a hablar con
él
ni sola ni acompañada entonces le digo
no hasta el momento en el que vayamos a
firmar el convenio yo voy hablo contigo
antes no
y entonces recuerdo
muchas mujeres actualmente sufren
violencia y tuvieron la intención de
hablar con el entrevistado
erróneamente fueron soles
y ellos no pueden encontrar su historia
para el caso de que tengan la
posibilidad y crean que se van a poder
solucionar las cosas no se acude sola
gracias a todo el apoyo que yo he tenido
a todos esos lazos que hacen en que se
han entretejido en torno a mi persona
yo he salido
y salir más fuerte
y entonces el día que hay que firmar el
convenio él acude no puede negarse
y le pide a las personas que están allí
que por favor salgan me preguntan
quieres que salgamos
les digo bueno van a estar afuera si
cualquier cosa estamos ok
entonces él se queda y me dice
pero te quiero ofrecer una disculpa por
todo lo que ha pasado
tomo
disculpa él aceptó
el acepto porque yo quiero vivir en paz
yo quiero tener la posibilidad d
cortar
y volver a hacer a reconstruir me a mí
misma
sólo por eso tomo la dice
porque a partir de eso dejo atrás todo
lo que ya no quiero seguir cargando
porque mi vida va a ser diferente desde
este momento hacia adelante
ya no voy a tener el temor de seguir de
brillar o de querer que no se moleste
por equis o por llegar por zeta
en el matrimonio la intención es crecer
juntos
luche por eso
porque quería que creciera junto conmigo
pero a veces sucede
que más bien era una competencia
y entonces para que no hubiese conflicto
dejaba de brillar para que lo hiciera
y llegó un momento
en el qué
yo misma me fui desdibujando
y dije ya no más tuvo que pasar un hecho
fuerte como para poner el freno
pero esa decisión no la tome de manera
abrupta me tomé mi tiempo
y este tiempo que me tome no lo tomes
sola había muchas personas había muchos
factores
que estaban conmigo
las mujeres sufrimos violencia
y la sufrimos de todos lados y a veces
no lo decimos
porque que van a decir si yo digo que
eso por violencia que soy débil
que no puedo que no me quiero
a las mujeres que acudían conmigo a
asesoría yo les preguntaba
tienes conocimientos
tienes algo bien
tienes personas que te apoyen
ingresos
porque son de los factores que hacen
muchas veces que haya dependencia
y entonces cuando yo me vi
dentro de la violencia dije
tengo ingresos
si tengo un inmueble
tengo muchas personas junto a mí
porque hay una construcción social
también que te dice aguanta
la persona que me siguió y me acompañó
en este proceso me decidí porque hasta
este momento yo le decía porque tenía
como proyecto mi familia y la vas a
seguir teniendo
y le vas a seguir teniendo y ahora en
paz
y dije sí
pero yo la quería todas juntas sobre un
techo y me decía pero eso no está bien
es a ese tenerlos ahí eso obligará al a
alguien a que esté cuando no quiere y
entonces no hay crecimiento
y cuando comienzo a socializar y dicen
divorciarte
pero ya estaba segura entonces no
importaba lo que me dijeran yo ya sabía
cuál era mi objetivo yo ya había tenido
mi duelo yo ya había dicho hacia
adelante
y puedo contar mi historia
y la intención es que muchas mujeres que
viven la violencia tengan la capacidad
de reflexionar y decir qué es lo que
quieren para ellas mismas para ustedes
cómo se proyectan
yo proyecte mis escenarios y ninguno era
bueno
hay mujeres que no tienen la oportunidad
y lo vemos cada día
encontrada muerta encontrada muerta
encontrada muerta
y más bien no es muerta es privada de la
vida porque alguien hizo eso
entonces la invitación es dentro de las
decisiones más importantes de la vida es
estudiar qué carrera van a estudiar a
qué se van a dedicar y la otra muy
importante es a quién van a elegir para
que esté junto a ustedes
a alguien que los va a ayudar a crecer o
alguien que los va a frenar y que en
algún momento van a tener que dejar
porque ustedes están destinadas y
destinados a volar
a seguir tejiendo lazos
porque para eso estamos para tejer lazos
para crecer
hombres y mujeres nacimos para ser
felices no para hacer un obstáculo unos
contra otros
entonces cuando hablamos de la violencia
también hay que hablar de todos los
factores y de que ciertamente las
políticas públicas la cuestión política
tiene que estar inmersa y no sólo somos
nosotras también son ellos
y si queremos una buena relación hay que
trabajarla entre los dos y desde donde
se trabaja
desde el noviazgo
y si queremos trabajar y erradicar esta
violencia hay que sumar a mujeres ya
hombres porque estamos implicados
y cómo hacerlo
hay que tejer lazos muchos lazos porque
en algún momento son los que te van a
atenuar
son los que te van a ayudar son los que
nuevamente te van a catapultar hacia tus
sueños gracias
[Aplausos]